-Our first guest tonight i
CNN's chief White House
correspondent,
anchors "The Lead"
and "State of the Union,"
and a best-selling author.
His latest novel, "The Devil May
Dance," was published this month
and is already
a "New York Times" best seller
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Jake Tapper.
How are you, Jake?
-Hey, Seth, how are you doing?
Good to see you.
-I'm doing very well.
I like that you have the title
of the book over your shoulder
That is very neat.
-Oh, did I?
Oh, I didn't even -- I didn'
even know that I did that.
I didn't even --
-You're a natural.
You're a natural
at self-promotion.
I really tip my cap.
-I just put the painting
up there on the wall.
By the way,
do you know what this is?
This is a hat that Tug McGra
gave to Henry Winkler.
-Really?
And then you broke into
Henry Winkler's house?
[ Laughter ]
-Henry Winkler, you know,
discovered that I was a Phillies
fan and sent it to me.
-That's really nice.
Did Tug McGraw sign it?
-It says 45 on it,
which I think was his number
but he did not sign it.
-So anybody could've
written that.
-It has sweat stains though,
so I assume those are
actually Tug McGraw's
sweat stains.
-This is the only thing.
So, Henry Winkler heard
I was a Red Sox fan,
and he sent me a hat
and he said it was Babe Ruth's
[ Laughter ]
I think what I'm saying here i
I think we should not
necessarily trust Henry Winkle
when he sends us
an old, sweaty hat.
-But here's the thing.
I did do some research
because you know me.
I like to research.
-Yeah.
-And the cast of "Happy Days
actually did do, like,
promotional baseball games
in the late '70s,
and they did actually go t
Philadelphia, I think, in '79.
So, I mean, it checks out
is all I'm saying.
It checks out.
-It lightly checks out.
[ Laughs ]
-I couldn't find any evidenc
that Tug McGraw
gave Henry Winkler the hat
but I also couldn't find
any reason why he would
concoct the story
and then send me
a sweaty ball cap.
-You know what?
I think the takeaway here should
be a reminder to all our viewers
that Henry Winkler is
possibly the nicest person
not only in show business
but any business.
-In the world.
-100%.
The nicest guy I've ever met
And I can't even understand.
Like, he's the Fonz.
Because the Fonz
wasn't particularly nice.
-No.
I mean, he was helpful,
you know,
whenever the jukebox
wasn't working.
[ Laughter ]
He would give it a bang.
And that was good for the gang
-Not the only thing he gav
a bang to, if you know what I --
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, you know what?
I'm pretty sure that didn'
actually happen on the show.
So, this is --
I want to talk about this
because you wrote the first of
your books, a best seller.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-And did you write that
with any sense
that you were gonna
write another one?
-No.
I mean, I thought,
"I hope it doesn't fail.
I hope people buy it.
I hope people read it.
I hope people like it."
And then once that happened,
I'm like, "Oh.
Maybe I can write another one.
And, you know, around that time,
I heard this crazy story
that was true that Sinatra
who had helped get JFK elected
had wanted President Kennedy
to stay at his compound
in Rancho Mirage,
and he had it all built up
a helipad
and phone lines and rooms.
And then Attorney General
Kennedy heard about this
and said, "I'm investigating
organized crime,
and Sinatra is actually friend
with mobsters.
I don't know about this trip."
And I heard about this
around that time.
I'm like, "Well, that's a grea
setting for the second book.
-So, these are, you know,
a lot of fictional character
in this book,
but you're also writing abou
real people,
and yet, in a fictional way,
which I am sure people
accuse you of doing on CNN
all the time.
-[ Laughs ]
Yes.
But this is actually fake news
-Okay, gotcha.
-This is the true fake news.
All of the stuff that we
reported about President Trump
et cetera, that, believe i
or not, although in many way
it's stranger than fiction
that actually happened.
-So, do you enjoy the research
that goes into a book like that,
and are you also particularl
drawn to that era
of American politics
and culture?
-I love that era.
And it's so glamorous
on its face
but also, underneath it,
really full of menace.
And I do like the research
I mean, I got into this business
because I love history.
I love it while it's going on.
I love it from 100 years ago
50 years ago.
So it's fun for me.
-You write about the Rat Pac
in this book.
Who are you in the CNN Rat Pack?
Are you the Sinatra of CNN
Are you the Dean?
-I'm kind of like
the Joey Bishop.
[ Laughter ]
The funny Jew who goes home to
his wife at the end of the day
-We thought that too,
but we didn't want to say it
We were hoping.
-[ Laughs ]
-We wanted to find out.
-The sweet family man.
The sweet family man.
-Yeah.
You know, it's interesting
I've heard you say a lot o
the people that were famou
in the time you set this boo
are still very famous.
It's really interesting.
-Yeah. It's incredible.
I mean, so many of the stars
back then,
and so many of the films
that I write about,
because when Charlie and
Margaret, my characters, go to
investigate whether or not
Sinatra is actually mobbed up,
having been enlisted to do s
by Attorney General Kennedy,
you know, they go to a movie set
of "The Manchurian Candidate,"
and they meet people
in addition to the Rat Pack --
Dean Martin, Peter Lawford
Sammy Davis Jr. --
they run into -- you know,
there's Alfred Hitchcock.
There's Tippi Hedren.
There's Janet Leigh.
I mean, all of these people.
It's incredible.
They're still so iconic,
and the movies are still
a part of our discourse,
part of popular culture.
-Well, you're very wise.
You're very wise to make tha
what your book was about.
I've known you to be a smart guy
for a long time,
and I am not surprised.
I have a lot more questions.
We'll be right back
with more from Jake Tapper